face à l'Entente Sportive du 16e les
féminines d' lancour doivent attendre la
fin de la première période pour voir les
filets trembler sur une ouverture plein
AX myiam Saibi évite la sortie de la
gardienne parisienne et marque dans le
but
vide les Amazones passent une grande
partie de la rencontre dans le camp
adverse avec une possession de Balding
du FC Barcelone et un jeu très direct à
une ou deux touches dans cette première
mi-temps les joueuses parisiennes ne
trouvent leur salut que sur coup de pied
arrêté à 45 minutes du titre les
joueuses de Dany maintiennent la
pression et dès le retour des vestièes
Caroline ogets profite de ce ballon
relâché par la gardienne parisienne pour
doubler la
mise preuve de la domination des
Amazones dans ce second acte les
joueuses parisiennes se procurent une
seule et unique occasion bien trop peu
pour inquiéter l'OSC cette saison en
cours le danger vient aussi du banc sur
son premier ballon elodi Bro parachève
le succès 5quantinois de l'intérieur du
gauche la fin de match est une formalité
au coup de sifflé final les Amazones
peuvent exulter elles sont titrées 4
journées avant la fin du championnat et
accèdent à la Promotion d'Honneur
vraiment de la joie on s'est battu toute
une saison pour arriver là là c'était un
peu le match consécration donc on s'est
mis un peu de pression mais euh ça fait
vraiment plaisir c'est quoi la clé du
succès euh la clé du succès c'est
euh c'est énormément d'assuité de
concentration et euh de solidarité en
fait parce que c'est l'esprit d'équipe
est super
important